you know the other great thing about
this decision the draft decision anyway
is that it completely ruined the night
for all of the libs at the met gala last
night um the met gala was was happening
with the theme gilded glamour
and uh they all showed up on the red
carpet so i want to go through
a little bit of a you don't expect
you're going to get this today but we're
going to do a little bit of a fashion
review let's just go through some of the
looks and first of all mayor eric adams
was there
and you know
he promised to put an end
to the violent crime epidemic in the
city lots of people were wondering uh
how he would do that
and
last night he finally unveiled his plan
to get rid of gun violence and there it
is there he's wearing a suit that says
end gun violence
and just like that
the violent crime epidemic
in new york city and indeed across the
entire country was was brought to an end
because of eric adams so that i thought
was was pretty courageous lots of other
creatures let's just go through some of
these i don't even know what you're
gonna put up on the screen okay so we
got this person here i don't know who
that person i don't know who any of
these people are
but she's got that uh little bit of um
if you i think it's a beautiful dress if
you want to look like a diseased bird or
maybe a pin cushion it's a great look go
to the next one
what else do we have here another so
it's more of the diseased bird look
okay now this this i like this right
here because this is kind of that um
if you're going for the pepto-bismol
vibe
and that vibe is really in right now so
i don't know who that is but it's a guy
with a full pink suit pink shoes and
everything that's a great look i'm
actually liking all these
okay this guy that's just if you want to
look stupid i guess you wear that we can
go to the next one
okay this one right here
that's the one this is like
if
edward scissorhands
had sex with a peacock
and then the kid grew up
and became addicted to meth
and was a sex offender that's what it
would look like all right i think we saw
enough there
and all of those people oh then there's
that's that one too there that's kind of
like if you if you get a bdsm outfit at
party city that's what you would i think
that's probably what that would look
like all those people they got dressed
up they got they spent thousands of
dollars on their on their nice outfits
and they went into the gala the banquet
and it's right then that the news
dropped
that roe v wade was it was is going to
be overturned and i just i love every
part of that
um even if the news never should have
been leaked in the first place
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated